[Music]  [Music]  oh we lost one i won  why priebus kg2 oh my god i miss  pre-moved any blood queen g2 rather  would you want a nice at that removed  that's insane all right  oh my god i won that how did i do that  i guess i'm not that old  ah nepo is a good wait i don't even know  what the format is to be honest  okay very good redemption  oh my god this freaking guy  oh my god  oh my god that's epic oh my god how did  i do that  i think it works  we've got to make sure this this can't  fail  this is nice  should be five bishop c3  only moves i think shut up random  i had to make sure of it it's the only  moves  oh my god daniel move  oh you freaking  let's go  okay  and that's why i don't mess with mr  narratives gilbert  in the south that's what happens  all right we're good  are you freaking serious  good games guitar games and  gutenginsen um thank you very much